SPEAKER: This
video shows you how
to create a Qwiklabs account.
You can skip this
section if you've already
created a Qwiklabs account.
If you do not have
a Qwiklabs account,
you can create one now.
If you already have
a Qwiklabs account,
you can skip this
section and go directly
to the section about
redeeming credits.
In a web browser, navigate
to google.qwiklabs.com.
On the Qwiklabs home
page, click Join.
Click Join with Email.
Enter your first and last
name and your email address.
Specify the same
email address that you
used for your Coursera account.
For company name, specify your
institution's name, or none.
Enter a password.
Enable the opt-in box to receive
additional Qwiklabs credits
after you complete the
cloud architecture quest.
Enable the "I'm not
a robot" CAPTCHA,
and click Create a New Account.
Check?
Your email account for an
account confirmation email
from Qwiklabs.
Click the link in the email
to confirm your account.